are you dealing with him having to go to
school at home i hate it
i hate it that's why he's doing bad and
i don't care
is he still allowed to hang out with
friends yeah he can hang out
oh god our poor teenager you know we
have a teenager
and um you have a teenager in the house
yeah and we
had a kid for 17 years and no one
[ __ ] knew no you know you know i had
a kid right
be real are you [ __ ] with me right
now no i thought you were joking
yeah yeah i've had a kid you're kidding
right
he said when you guys met in vegas no
bobby look at my [ __ ] face i've
always had a daughter
juliana yeah
you're [ __ ] with me no no i've always
had a daughter
it's not kalila's it wasn't the mother
she's like the stepmother no i know that
but i didn't know you had a dog no i
have a daughter and she was with um
my one of my ex except girlfriends also
filipino
also filipina and she um
she raised you know um my daughter
juliana for about
14 years and now but then juliana lives
with me now
wow bro yeah you want to call her
upstairs yeah she'd bring her down her
no because why not because she because
then she had to wear one of the mask and
probably sleeping low-key yes school
right so she sleeps during you know
no no i'm with you on that yeah my son
he that's what he's doing right now too
and uh i can't you you never uh honestly
no are you [ __ ] you're [ __ ] with 1
million bobby i had no idea you don't
know that i had a daughter
no you've met her before bobby no i have
not he hasn't
i've never met your daughter you must
have and i just met your brother
two years ago but i had a brother but i
always knew you had a brother yeah yeah
you always knew i had a brother but you
never
knew i had a dog i never i never knew
you had a dog you know why you didn't
never know how i had a daughter
because you didn't tell me i'm not your
friend i don't i don't have one
i apologize i'm so sorry i just
he looked at me and i had to like go
with it
there is a teenager here though we have
a teenager
from the philippines that feels so good
dude
[ __ ] you and your corona tequila of a
commercial number one with my mom
being [ __ ] you i got you uh
yeah what you gonna do bro fro oh
that really sucks what because i really
believed you i know i don't have a
daughter and guess what happens now
what trust is gone no what happens now i
don't trust you no you don't know what
happens now is you
you ride your bike because he wrote his
bike here how do i write it
right right yeah like like
a rickshaw right and uh you're gonna go
i was bamboozled
wow yeah you're a bamboo why do you hate
filipinos so much i love them that's a
good question no
you should really i [ __ ] love them is
it because you have like um
like a deep like jealousy no
filipinos because we're very there was a
guy named eric sarmianto
there it is there it is here's the core
there's the core
okay so here's the evil so when i was in
the fifth grade
so i lived in minnesota up until like